everybody shut up and let him speak I
need to know no we need to open up too
we no no no I didn't like anony for a
long time even though we've been on so
many shows tours whatever together okay
like disliked or just didn't like he
[__] hated you
[Music]
dude welcome back to careful boys where
we are scared of literally everything
and today we're talking about is
flirting and texts
cheating oo
flirting what constitutes yeah what cons
SL you tell me boys it's a dangerous
world out there you could send an emoji
too many emojis you could emphasize it
better not be that one with the little
squirty water what's flirting to you
guys eggplant eggplant it's flirting
Peach is it it's flirting when you feel
something toward them and you enjoy
their attention and
affection I think I think it has to do
with intention too cuz like let's say
you have a friend that's a chick I I
think there's a difference between
messing around like she's your sister
and just like goofing around sending
text back and forth you guys don't flirt
with your sisters versus like texting
with like um a different type of like
romantic messing around you know cuz
there's to me there's like flirting like
that was funny trying to F and then
there's like there's like flirting like
that's a flirt that's a little flirt
that's like you're so funny so funny
let's uh you just open up I'm a little
flirty or how about when you're you're
texting this person in mind you're like
smiling all time and then you keep like
deleting the text again and rewriting it
that that that's you're flirting
flirting for because you're putting too
much thought into it you're like and
you're nervous yeah you're nervous dude
that's I think that's what about being
like ha gotcha funny jokes time you want
[__] want to [__] yeah if you say like
like want to [__] ha funny jokes time
then it's all good all right what about
what about this what about like what
about somebody from like way the like
way back hitting you up going like how
come we never like you know how come we
never had a thing me you how come we
never like got it done yeah how you
harass me out are you allowed to even
engage I'll be like my dick was busy
elsewhere you know what you do good
question you hit him with the thumbs up
you just hit him with the thumbs
up that's bad English or you go Shaka no
that's bad English or you just like you
like the comment it's bad English
because they asked a how come question
which requires a description but that's
how you get out but it also depends on
your intention after that it's like are
you trying to like talk to figure it out
because cuz let's say let's say somebody
did do that to me right and I'd be like
okay I I wouldn't feel bad answering
this and having that conversation if I
didn't feel bad like showing my partner
and being like look this person hit me
up blah blah blah like how much you want
to cover it up yeah but if it's like uh
I want to have this conversation but I
don't want to like I'm afraid to then I
think that's that's the weird L what you
like the Spider-Man pointing me I'm like
you're like Spider-Man's pointing at
Spider-Man and it's like it's like that
that is [__] up that might be your
flirting though that's that's what I'm
think I do think sharing that affection
that's supposed to be for your
significant other and you don't want
them to know and you know that that will
hurt them that's kind of flirting and
that is cheating yeah [__] damn you just
went like you did both wait wait wait
give him a second to go want a [__] all
right got
CU if my wife saw me texting somebody
and she thought it was flirting she'd be
like that's cheating she would just
immediately [__] go there cuz and she
kick my ass laughing together kick your
ass can easily lead to a 69 easily
easily said what laughing together can
be
like that can happen wait which rooll
were
you I heard a oh like like your mouth
went around something I was I was the
girl that was sucking my dick okay Ryan
you got good babe I was the
girl I was the girl dude babe I was the
girl I was the girl babe you're not even
[__] listening to me actually you're
just you're not listening to what I'm
saying you know what what what about
this there's some people that think that
like sending memes is like
flirting what's the memes I don't know
about that just funny [__] if you're
doing it all day yeah it is yeah it is I
I like Anthony's gauge cuz it's like
let's say you are sending memes back and
forth right but then you can show your
like look we send like me and Sarah been
sending mes back and forth if it's all
good then it's all good but then if it's
like like scrolling like dude you guys
been sending memes for like [__] two
three days straight and then there's
like all the other your eyes are red and
you're just like yeah like if they feel
uncomfortable then it is uncomfortable
yeah that's true cuz you're breaching
your own set rules yeah or if yeah or if
you start questioning it like oh should
I like yeah yeah yeah too deep then
that's too far right I like Anthony's
Gage too cuz he cuz he's like babe look
I I do it with everybody look it's
everybody and it's like 15 girls oh yeah
so basically if you're flirting with
somebody you just have to do that with
all your boys too everybody see I do it
every single see that's true what's the
big deal like I send this sperman meme
to everybody I think I think there's a
lot of levels of I think there's
different levels of it yeah cuz there's
like quick little cuz I I think there's
no harm in quick little flirting with
strangers cheating oh cuz like okay like
if Hannah here's a drink sexy can I buy
you a drink but that's it thanks for
coming to June so if like let's say
Hannah's like at Starbucks and [__]
right and then like somebody like he I
just want to let you know you're like
[__] cute as [__] and then she's like
oh my God that's so funny thank you like
you made my day and [__] she doesn't say
that but she'll just be like oh not not
not I don't want y I don't want y you
know say'll say holy [__] was that
Hannah yeah holy [__] I don't want you I
don't want you sound just like her yeah
it does sound like her so close and then
um what if she at Starbucks right she
sees the the the guy at the Brie it's
like she's like wow you're very handsome
and fit that's it your fit night that
well that pissed me off that made me mad
she she she she could like that o I
think o you got a
license a playful exchange for a quick
moment boys where two adults are
appreciating how hot they are real quick
or whatever or if it's a joke cuz it
could be a playful joke right where it's
kind of like not joke serious like not
even about your looks like in flirting
it can be just like you're clearly like
oh this person's hot there you think
they think you're hot whatever and then
you joke and you have a little like
banter or whatever right and then you're
like all right I'm keep it right there
or something like that but you're you're
you have like a little more cuck Vibes
than I think we do
but I do it too so I'm allowing it cuz I
like that makes sense but that's what
I'm saying is like you know what I'm
talking about it's like it's not full on
like but saying that someone's [__]
cute is kind of like pretty direct yeah
but I'm not doing that [__] yeah yeah
yeah but your chick is no okay okay but
if she was if someone were to do that to
her so this is the point I'm trying to
make okay if someone took it gave it to
her and she was like oh you made my day
ego flexx but I don't want you I don't
know if that's actually fully flirting
but she got to receive the flirt she's
actually just playing it cool honestly
like cuz sometimes you have she didn't
reciprocate you have to take a
compliment from a guy sometimes just to
make cool thanks you made my
day she didn't reciprocate I wouldn't
consider that flirting oh cuz like so
let's say old lady flirt with me right
she goes oh are you going to be the guy
helping me out today and I'm like yeah
ooh it's my lucky day or whatever right
right and then I'll flirt with a old
[__] cuz start grabbing her by the hips
you know what I mean but it doesn't mean
anything Joe's like yeah but I do I do
try to imagine her when she was 27 and
I'm like one day you 80-year-old [__] I
wish I was back to the future with you
you know and then like old lady has
something in her hair you just go oh let
me just get that out of your eye for you
you know that's cute you know I mean so
I do think it's a lot of it is intention
because in your mind you know you're not
going to [__] the 80-year-old but I wish
I did she but then if she was super hot
and she was
then it's because now are you are you
scared of your own self in that you know
then I think that's where it get start
to get fish the thing is we all know if
we're being sus yeah we all know in our
deepest darkest moments if we're being
sus yeah and so only you can regulate
what you're texting and why you're
texting it being honest with yourself
yes you know what's funny too though is
like even without the like flirting
aspect if a girl was to just start
talking to me about something she like a
sexual experience with another person
not me and just was telling me about it
I think that's considered flirting to
smack she doesn't like that [__] you say
one more time like let's say that when
girls be talking about how they were
sucking a [__] out let's say you just
hanging out with some girl you guys are
not flirting at all and she's like she's
like oh my God this guy made me suck his
dick last night it was [__] horrible
oh my God the veins the sex was whack
blah blah BL I think my gagy fck is
[__] broken yeah like even that ra
you we're not actually even flirt we're
not talking about our own intentions or
nothing she just tell me a story just
her opening up the Pandora's Box that's
already a breach because it's like why
you getting that familiar to [__]
talking smack smart cuz that's that's
yeah then you go H I have a
girlfriend um um cuz of her girlfriend
whatever cuz that's something that that
happens sometimes where it's like oh
she's not flirting with me she's not
like [__] you know yeah yeah but why
are you guys talking about that subject
exactly yeah why do why am I even enter
or when she says that you go
okay and you walk away that's good I
think it's the best when they end it
with oh if there was only a guy that can
[__] me right and in that moment you're
[Laughter]
like hold on SEC hold on
hold hold on hold on that's another
thing where like some things are not
necessarily flirting but it's just like
the familiarity of the topic is is too
danger zone yeah it's danger zone yeah
yeah yeah well cuz some people go it's
not actually cheating unless you
actually have sex so everything before
that is okay if that's your rule in the
relationship then but that's whack rule
just a foreplay yeah some people just
have more like like playroom than others
but you know just depends I guess I
would say if you're
sharing intimacy with
someone that isn't your significant
other whether it's physical or mental or
emotional then that can that can that
can kind of that's basically cheating
yeah there's like otal cheating you and
you know if you're doing it like my
thing like I used to text Nikki right
cuz we were both in our comedy troop
together and like like our little sketch
group and like we would just text each
other cuz we had a bit with each other
which was like unsubscribed like
whatever you say to me I just
unsubscribe to you right and then like
so like I would be like at that candy
store uh like in in that big mall like
outside um where the AMC theater is and
I saw an unsubscribed like kitchen mag
and I [__] texted Nikki that picture
but I didn't I and I swear this is true
I never had like oh I like this girl or
anything I'm like a rider right so I was
just riding and riding with my chick but
I was just like that's funny Nikki will
laugh at that it was like when we're
friends but like I know that I didn't
send that to be sus but now looking back
I'm like wo I married that chick lat but
was it subconscious sus I I I don't
think so but like that does [__] with me
a little bit cuz I'm like wow me and
Nikki like we used to [__] with each
other that way way but I know for a fact
I never thought about her like that
except for one time but that was like
the Friendship though that was like but
that was when me and my chicks our
relationship started to crumble after I
found out she cheated on me and then I
had some thoughts about me I think that
makes sense cuz even like when me and
smack were friends we joked around that
was our main Rapport was just jokes and
I never one time thought of her like in
any other way was just ball busted but
what if she saw you you that way I don't
think she she dated different dudes too
and I met the guys she was dating and it
was all like were you dating somebody
else at that time yeah I was like would
that person have approved of the way
that you were joking with smack no there
was actually a point in time when uh so
this is the thing there was a point in
time where like I because like I just
saw smack like that we went to this like
event and then this other girl who I
guess like thought was the girl to me
was like you just been talking to smack
all day like started complaining about
it and I was like yeah cuz we're [__]
friends and we joke about [__] why is
that like weird then I think it's both
ways it's not just like you know when
you're sus because in that situation or
that situation you didn't have the
intention and you didn't think you were
being sus but the partner the partner
thought it was sus so it's not cheating
but it is flirting that comes yeah that
comes back to the thing of whatever you
did and whatever I did we we didn't have
the intention but if a person were to
point that out and go look at this we
also don't have right to be perfectly
innocent about no we can you can but
you're you're setting the boundary now
CU now I understand the boundary and
before I was like dude we're we're just
balling like I didn't know the bumpers
were up or whatever now I know where
they're at but that wasn't cheating that
was just sus suser you know what I mean
can't stop connection but yeah exactly
that's what I was going to say like
connection and chemistry is also hard
yeah because sometimes it does just
happen then I flirt with guys all the
time you sure do honestly I I didn't
really like Anthony for a long time tell
Stanford same and we've been around each
other for a long time it wasn't until
the tattoos for
me like 48 hours
I everybody shut up and let him speak I
need to know no we need to open up too
we no no no I didn't like Anthony for a
long time even though we've been on so
many shows tours whatever together like
disliked or just didn't like he [__]
hated you dude I I also hate a lot of
people during that time anyway but
during Stanford it was like fireworks
for some reason I don't know why we we
became like good friends he was sus that
trip right so but stuff but stuff like
that but like that if you put that in a
romantic sense I also think that's why
it's really important like those
conversations you're talking about
sometimes chemistry and connection will
happen beyond your control so you need
to give yourself even more buffer zone
away from the danger zone so it's a
preemptive act yeah cuz you could put
yourself in a bad situation but there's
like actual fireworks happen youge and
you don't think about it and then later
a week later you're like oh [__] I think
I caught feelings like after because
some [__] happened you know well I
didn't like you either yeah n you
did n you
did we all we all said same at the
same did you say it you guys said it so
many times to make it sound like all of
us said it go back to the [__]
footage it same sa sa sa same and me and
you weren't saying anything I was
throwing my voice over there I was like
why were there four people made Joe say
it
dude Tyler said it
dude he pops it like yeah yeah yeah none
of us like say same like the grill guy
comes back he's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
fcking hate this place the Postmates guy
he's
like fantastic yeah can we edit that
last part
[Music]
out